[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain an american drama film called
flight which is loosely inspired by the
plane crash of alaska airlines flight
261.
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie starts in a hotel room where
pilot whip whitaker wakes up with one of
his flight attendants katarina marquez
the condition of the room tells us that
they had a wild night of alcohol
cigarettes and intercourse
whip's ex-wife calls him to talk about
their son but whip dismisses her saying
that they can talk later
katarina gets ready and leaves for the
airport for the next flight while whip
is still hungover he snorts a line of
cocaine to wake himself up and gets
ready
whip then gets to the airport and into
the flight he is welcomed by katarina
and another flight attendant named
margaret thomason he meets his co-pilot
ken evans as the two prepare for the
flight whip asks margaret for an aspirin
claiming he hasn't slept in two days
somewhere else a drug addict prostitute
named nicole comes out of a hotel room
after a night with her client she goes
directly to her dealer's place and asks
him for drugs he offers her to be in an
adult movie for money but she declines
she buys a small quantity of heroin from
him the dealer warns her to be careful
with the drug because it hasn't been cut
back in the flight whip and ken take off
despite the bad weather they ascend a
little aggressively ken seems to notice
whip's weird behavior but doesn't say
anything whip asks to fly the plane
himself instead of keeping it on
autopilot the turbulence gets worse as
they reach a higher altitude whip then
levels off the original route to find a
pocket of smooth air he pushes the plane
higher and faster in an attempt to make
it reach a higher altitude ken is
nervous about the decision but whip
assures him that he knows what he is
doing ken reports to flight control that
they are diverting from their original
path because of the weather whip takes
the plane to a safer level and
stabilizes it the turbulence finally
stops and the passengers applaud in
appreciation of the pilots
meanwhile nicole reaches her home and
sees her perverted landlord inside he is
there to ask her for the due rent she
forcefully sends him outside to wait
until she showers but instead she brings
out the drug and injects herself with it
as she feels its effects the landlord
yells at her to open the door
at the same time whip comes out of the
cockpit to apologize to the passengers
for the aggressive takeoff while
announcing this he pours three mini
vodka bottles into an orange juice and
drinks it
some time later margaret walks into the
cockpit to see the plane on autopilot
and whips sleeping peacefully the
mission control informs ken that the
plane is ready to descend as he presses
a few keys aggressive turbulence pushes
the plane forward waking whip up the
passengers start to panic margaret asks
everyone to fasten their seat belts
quickly canon and whip try to control
the plane but the steering mechanisms
don't seem to work now they are going on
a straight dive without control they
inform the mission control about the
hydraulics not working but receive no
useful feedback whip stays perfectly
calm and asks ken to ditch the plane's
fuel he also tries several different
emergency maneuvers to bring the plane
back under control but is unsuccessful
whip calls margaret into the cockpit to
help him pull down a lever she straps
herself in place and helps the pilot but
the plane doesn't stabilize
a forceful jerk makes one of the
stewardesses hit her head and falls
unconscious as the plane is about to hit
the ground whip has an idea he asks ken
to retract the flaps and the gears
because they are going to roll down then
he asks margaret to say i love you to
her son because the black box is
recording he knows that saving the plane
is not possible now whip gets a little
control of the steering and rolls the
plane upside down to make it go at a
lower speed and buy them some time to
find a safer landing spot the stewardess
who fell earlier rolls around and falls
to the ceiling the passengers are in a
panic when one little boy mistakenly
unstraps himself katarina goes to help
him and fastens his seatbelt below
nicole's landlord and a paramedic rescue
her as she has overdosed they too see
the upside down plane flying in the sky
back in the plane whip keeps himself
composed but ken starts to panic
both of the engines fail at the same
time whip turns the airplane over again
ready to crash land they slowly descend
to a field and one wing hits a church's
tower shearing it off
the plane then slams onto the field
whip's head bangs against the steering
yoke and he is knocked out we see
katarina's body lying limp on the ground
as margaret cries in the background the
paramedics arrive and rescue the
passengers and the crew members the
plane is broken in half
whip wakes up on a hospital bed and sees
his friend and a pilot's union
representative charlie anderson in his
room
charlie praises him for saving a lot of
lives as it turns out only six of the
102 people on the plane died including
katarina another stewardess and four
passengers his co-pilot is in a coma
whip has incredibly managed to save a
lot of people considering the situation
they were in the people from national
transportation safety board ntsb come to
interview him and leave after asking
some questions shortly after whip's
friend harling brings whip some
cigarettes and alcohol but whip refuses
to drink harling informs him that his
home is surrounded by the media who are
dying to take his interview his heroic
deed is being praised by everyone whip
asks harling to bring his clothes and
belongings to the hospital because he is
getting discharged the following day
later whip goes to the hospital
staircase to smoke and comes across
nicole the prostitute who had previously
overdosed a talkative cancer patient
joins the two
the three smoke while talking about
several things the patient believes that
there's no way to stop things from
happening like him getting cancer and
whiplanding the plane the three of them
meeting there was also inevitable
after he leaves whip asks for nicole's
address and promises to visit one day
after being discharged harling takes
whip to his family home on a farm
because his home is surrounded by the
reporters when he gets to the farmhouse
he pours all the alcohol in the house
down the drain he has made his decision
to get sober
later whip gets a call from charlie who
invites him to meet a lawyer named hugh
lang he goes to meet them and gets to
know that the ntsb has found out about
him being intoxicated before the flight
since someone has to compensate for the
deaths of the passengers they are likely
to blame wep for being intoxicated which
can result in life imprisonment whip
doesn't take this information well and
goes to the bar and starts to drink
again he buys a bulk of alcohol on his
way back and stops by nicole's place her
landlord is forcefully trying to get
money from her whip gets there just in
time and gets him off of her he offers
the man some money and brings nicole to
his farmhouse after realizing she has
nowhere to go that night the two end up
having sex
over the next few days whip continues to
avoid the press but soon realizes that
his reputation could be plagued by the
others who are around him at katarina's
funeral he meets margaret who claims she
could tell that whip was drunk when she
encountered him that morning whip then
starts to get personal claiming that if
not for him she could have ended up dead
as well whip then visits ken at the
hospital ken explains he hasn't told the
ntsb who have been investigating the
crash about his suspicions on whip's
condition at the time ken knows whip was
hung over in the cockpit and that he may
have been drunk when the accident
occurred even though he may never walk
again ken and his wife believe that his
survival was a miracle the couple is
strictly religious and insist that whip
pray with them which he does reluctantly
meanwhile nicole has been turning her
life around getting a job at a grocery
store and has been attending self-help
meetings to sober up from drug addiction
she takes whip with her to one of the
meetings but an uninterested whip leaves
partway through shortly afterward nicole
finds whip working on the cessna in his
father's garage whip tries to persuade
nicole to fly to jamaica with him she
stops him and claims that he needs rehab
which angers whip the two get into an
argument and nicole storms off into the
house the following morning nicole
leaves him a note and flees from the
farmhouse with her luggage saddened by
her departure whip starts to drink even
more one day he comes back to his
farmhouse to see reporters waiting for
him with nowhere else to go he rushes to
his ex-wife's house however since he is
drunk his family does not want him there
whip gets into an argument with his son
and is kicked out of the house outside
the media surround him he manages to get
away after giving vague answers to their
questions charlie is outraged by whip's
alcoholism they are trying to prove that
he wasn't intoxicated on the flight but
he is making it harder by drinking every
day for the next eight days whip stays
with charlie hugh has managed to have
whip's alcohol test thrown out on a
technicality but they still need to have
whip present his side of the story to
ellen block the investigator for the
ntsb the evening before the hearing whip
is brought to his hotel room nervousness
gets the best of him that night he
cannot sleep or go through the documents
that he had prepared for him when he
looks at the room's mini-fridge he finds
all kinds of alcohol have been removed
however he discovers a door that leads
him to the room next door the
mini-fridge inside that room is fully
stocked with alcohol whip tries to
control himself but is unsuccessful the
following day is the day of the hearing
charlie and hugh knock on his door when
whip doesn't open it they walk in using
an extra set of keys they are shocked to
find the room trashed and bottles of
alcohol scattered everywhere whip is in
the bathroom completely drunk and out of
his mind he asks charlie to call harling
and bring him some cocaine charlie and
hugh have no other way to get whip back
to his senses before the hearing so they
agree
harlan comes to the hotel room and
snorts cocaine along with whip whip then
gets ready and leaves the hotel
confidently at the hearing block doesn't
suspect whip at all she instead claims
that the cause of the plane
dysfunctioning was a damaged jack screw
in the tail of the plane that was
supposed to be repaired a few years ago
the jack screw forced the tail
stabilizer to turn around which caused
the plane to dive however after saying
that block reveals that they have found
two empty bottles of vodka in the crash
which were only accessible to the flight
crew she adds that katarina who has a
history of alcoholism must have had the
alcohol and asks whip what he thinks
whip goes silent for a few seconds and
finally admits that he drank the vodka
not katarina everyone present at the
hearing gasps and charlie tries to
object but is dismissed whip finally
confesses that he was drunk and high
while piloting the plane and he is drunk
right now too
in the following scene we see whip in
prison with his fellow prisoners he
tells them that the hearing was his
breaking point and he could not lie
anymore it has been 13 months since the
hearing he believes that he will be
there for the next four years
while in prison he is sobered up and
improved his relationship with his wife
and son we see his son visit whip to
learn more about his father he refers to
whip as the most fascinating person he
has never met and takes his interview
for his college essay subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching